absolutely um all right talk to me about
bitcoin uh and the context here is
uh marty bent which many people in the
bitcoin community will know
uh used to work at bar stool and he red
pilled
a good number of people at bar stool you
were one of them so tell us kind of like
what was the first time you ever heard
of bitcoin
what were those conversations like marty
uh like as well
well first of all you're the first
person to ever say
tell me what you think about bitcoin
because i'm used to people saying caleb
shut up about bitcoin caleb shut up we
don't care we get it we know
um so marty was
hired at barstool we called him i know
him as bitcoin marty
you know him as marcus dent i know him
as bitcoin marty
bitcoin marty got hired at barstool
literally as
he had like some type of fake job that
we were paying him for on paper his job
was the crypto guy
because dave was getting into crypto and
we had another guy named lightswitch lou
who's also he's also doesn't work at
barcelo anymore who's the one who knew
marty and brought him in he was in
crypto and then
at barcelo marty got me in the crypto
maybe a few other guys
um and i had like the most classic
story getting into bitcoin because marty
comes along
i'm i meet him like what's this guy's
deal oh this is bitcoin marty well
what's bitcoin
he starts doing tell me about bitcoin
i'm like all right i'll throw a few
bucks at it
cool well then it was what 2017 in the
fall
and so i throw like whatever 100 bucks
at bitcoin
all of a sudden my 100 bucks is you know
150 bucks
pretty quick like within a couple like a
week or something it was like
right when it was going off so i was
like oh this is like
i got to get on this train now like this
is this train is leaving the station and
i have to
put everything i own into bitcoin so
this is my personality you can already
tell by
going all the way on golf i think all my
money that i have
all of it here's all the money i have
and i put it on the b i put in a bitcoin
every single dollar that i had to my
name that wasn't tied up in something
else
well then bitcoin starts kind of slowing
down right it didn't crash
but it was like slowing down i'm not
talking about the over the course of
months
i mean like a couple days it was slowing
down and i wasn't getting that
that that hit i was like the hit of
adrenaline when it was going up i was
like
watching coinmarketcap.com and all of a
sudden i'm seeing bitcoin
you know plus .04
growth and then i'm seeing all these
other coins go 32
25 whatever so i and i
ask marty i say bitcoin marty what's the
deal with these other coins
why why are they going up so much are
they going to be the big ones
and i don't know at this point he's
given me the speech about what
cryptocurrency is what blockchain
blockchain technology is what a
decentralized currency could mean for
humanity
and all at this point i'm thinking about
is the green
plus however much percent and he says
caleb
dude do not go into these all coins he's
like if i can give you any piece of
advice
it would be hold your bitcoin do not go
into these all coins if you want to go
into the all coins
this monero might have some value
because it's
you know of its secret nature and it's
still you know
whatever he's like but i wouldn't even
he's like if you want to put some money
in that okay
if you want to diversify but
he's like i'm telling you man these all
coins ain't where it's at
says all right bitcoin marty i said
you've got me far enough i'll
i'm done taking your advice so you got
me into bitcoin i've i've abused you
and your brain almost caleb's brain's
taken over now
so i put all the money that was in
bitcoin
move it to the all coins right and i'm
not talking about like
the altcoins that are uh at first it was
like ripple
in ethereum well then those get boring
you know and then you see the ones that
are hitting 300 percent
so before you know it i get carried away
i got
all my money's tied up in these random
and
i've got the ones that you have to get a
download like software onto your
computer
just so you can get on to the uh the
exchange where they hold this coin
i was in some oh it was like q cash
something that was in china and it was
like
you had to download their service thing
was called like liquid
it has since like went out of business
and they like they sent an email like if
you had money here
sorry you can no longer access it
anyways but
all you need to know is that i've moved
my money over here bitcoin tanks
obviously the all coins tank even worse
i lost
everything i lost every dollar of
everything that i had boom poof out the
window
cryptocurrency and that's how i got into
bitcoin
all right you're still here though so
explain what happens
after you lose everything i lose
everything
and i have to laugh at myself because
i'm like i'm an idiot
proven time and time again idiot um
never cease to amaze myself idiot
then it goes on bitcoin kind of uh goes
down i can't remember what it was at the
time
i want to say it was like 4 000 or
something low
and uh and so you and and bitcoin marty
you know
he's popular at bar still whenever uh
bitcoin was going up
because i think dave had bought some big
cat bought some but then
bitcoin crashes you know i don't think
anyone's gonna say it to his face but
you know you kind of have a little bit
of like you know
this guy got everyone on bitcoin we all
lost all our money
um and anyway he ended up leaving he's
in and
but i love marty so and it wasn't he
wasn't fired because of bitcoin i came i
think he left on his own volition i
think he took another job
but everyone was like freaking bitcoin
marty lost us all this money so
probably a year later i was like or
maybe six months later it's like let's
go get some
a beer and let's hang out cause i
haven't seen you i miss you so we're
talking i'm like so what's going on
bitcoin dude
like tell me what you think now and he
just
really he talked to me about one how he
had always felt the same thing
about it his thoughts hadn't changed but
then he's really talking to me about
some of the deeper issues with bitcoin
and and some of the
what he believes is are you know some of
the progress is like society could make
from from adopting
bitcoin and he gave me some kind of
materials i could look at and look more
into
and for the first time ever he told me
about
um kind of the the
stages of currency that um the united
states has went through
uh over the years and how basically
right now we're not backed up by
anything and
he really kind of like put some real
thoughts in my mind that were outside of
the just the numbers going up
and so he kind of gave me some stuff to
look at so i go and i look at it and i'm
doing more research and so i start
buying in a little bit
you know at low and i'm like you know i
kind of do still think this is
this it is something um
and then i kind of just slowly getting
in kind of watching it go up and then
i'm really thinking more about it and i
don't have and i know you're showing
this why i'm a fan of your shows you
have
experts come on and they have so much
extensive knowledge of the
what's what's happening that's not me
but i do think i have
a little bit of knowledge about or at
least i have a feel
it's more of a feel thing of what's
popular and trends and things that are
uh
that have legs you know with what's
coming up whether it's like
we get on we got on tick tock really
early not really really early but like
once we saw it we were on tick tock uh
and i said we me and another guy who i
do a thinker account with
or a daily fact account or something
like tick tock or even like a new band
you know
you see something like this has legs
something about it is exciting and it's
and it and it makes sense on a lot of
levels and i could see this being big
um that's kind of how i felt about
bitcoin still and i still do to this day
and it's the main reason why i'm in it
is because
i look at bitcoin and i say you know
there's obviously some issues here
uh it's obviously very speculative but
when you look at the next generation of
kids i have a 10 year old 10 years
younger than me brother
and his world is so different than mine
with
technology and you know all of their
relationships
my little brother's really good about it
getting with his friends being with him
on a personal level but i see his
friends
too it's all phone everything's
phone and i'm kind of in the generation
where
or my age group is it's a lot of fun but
there's also a lot of personal
interaction
10 years younger than me it's almost 90
phone it's they talk to each other a
snapchat
in the same room or everything that's
happening is digital
10 years younger than that i mean they
have no chance of human to human
interaction how we used to do it so
i'm thinking about all right these kids
are they gonna think about when they
think about money or they think about an
asset like i personally and i don't know
up from down
so don't take my word for it i'm just
telling you what i think um
i kind of think that bitcoin has more
legs as an asset than it does as a
currency
just for the reason that when you talk
if i told my little brother about the
value of gold
it would be the actual goal it's like
hard to get it's like what do you get a
gold bar it doesn't really make sense
it's not like apple it's not intuitive
it's like you have to do more explaining
to uh
to explain to someone this is gold this
is how you get it this is why it's
valuable
then you would have to do for bitcoin
and pretty much the
at the end of the day you're coming back
to the same argument of why is
why is gold valuable if i really had to
explain to my little brother or someone
who's younger than him
i would eventually have to say well it's
basically just valuable because everyone
else says it is
you know that's the same thing for
bitcoin
because there is no inherent value of
you know holding a bar or
it's i think it just for people who are
in the digital age
whereas people now and older than me
probably think about
well it's just digital so it's really
not there it's if
it's ethereal it's in the floating in
the air you know it doesn't make sense
it's not
it's not real it's not grounded in real
life my
take is that life grounded in real life
is disappearing very quickly and i think
10 years from now 15 years from now
the amount of life that's happening as
we understand it in
actual you know it's it's not that
there's a digital world over here on the
right
and then everything that is in the
digital world is just a reflection of
what's happening in our actual
reality i think that the reality of
what's
actually happening what actually matters
is going to be almost
entirely in the digital world for
example
right now you look at like a twitter
twitter is a social media that you kind
of report
you report back on your thoughts about
what's happening in
our material world or in our reality
but then you look at something like
which i think twitter's on the way out
i do i hate twitter it's getting so
terrible i get on it because it work if
it wasn't for work i wouldn't even be on
twitter
but tick tock you know i don't know
where it's heading it looks like it's
kind of
where with president trump right now but
tick tock it's not a reflection of
what's going on
in the real world it is its own world
tick tock
is its own entire world similar
to youtube youtube is you go into
youtube and it's like that is its own
reality it's not a report back
necessarily on what's happening
in the real world so i'm just thinking
about
the future i see it as
that we're going to be living inside the
youtube and the tick tocks and just the
internet sphere that is going to be the
basis of our reality
and it makes so much more sense
intuitively
to have something that's a store of
value like bitcoin
that exists and works with that world
opposed to a gold that
you know i'm not saying gold's not gonna
be valuable but uh
you know it just doesn't make quite as
much
i guess intuitive sense